.
JOAQUI, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BH USING.
>> THANKS FOR VI ME.
>>> HE BIPARTISAN SENATE
HE CAPITOL RR GSTERDAYE HUGEURYE
TR I
EXAMINATION OF
BUT  THAT, ONE NETWORK -
GUESS WHICH Y MUCH ALTOGETHER.I
T'Y ASFIO N HONEST ACCOUNTINNED6
WITHOUT MENTIONING FOX NEWS,
HOGOING TOER
REGARDING THE
INSUEC
IT TURNS OUT THEY LARGELY 'T.
I  UP VERAGE, AND C.
BY N MOST NEWS
YORK TIMES," THE "WASHINGTON ST.
REPORTS OF WHAT HAPPENEDAT TOOK
MONTHS A
AT NIGHTTIME THINGS WERE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT, BUT INSTAMINII
RADICALIZING AMERICANS INT
BLAME AT TION WAS  F TRUMP, THY
E CAPITO.
HERE'S A CLIP FROM TUCKER
CARLSON'NIGHT.
>> IT BASICALLY REALLYLAE OLICE
ARE TOLD WER SIMIL
THE HEROES STORMEDORMANDY, AND
U.S. PIPOLICE
NOT PREPARED.PROTESTERS WERE LE
POLICE OERWE KNOW THEY WER
SELFIES.OR THE I
E SUPREMACISTSOLSUPREMISTS, TH U
Y ABOU JOHN, OBVIOUSLY THERE
WERE SECURITY FAILURES ON BELF
AUTHORIT THIS REPORT LAID L QUER
WH THINK THADEMOCRATIC SYSTEM FD
THTHINGS INTO
THEIR OWN  Y
K AT FOX RTHEY SEEM TO NOT WANT
THINKS OLIVER DOOR UM REALLRETA
STUNNING.OR, AMANDA, THAWA
EE FL DO EVEIN
TO SAY,, THE
THE FAULT  T  WASN'T
ISTS OR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT?
>>WAS ECURITLEM.WHEN MITCH McCO
WAS  PROBLEMY
POLITICAL VIOLENCE.ITYREIS WASN
PRESIDENT.
THAT.DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
DONALD T THE SENATE REPORT
S AND LISTENO WHAT TRE HE PRESIV
EC SAIT UP.
INSTEAD THEY WANLAME THE
I MEAN- I T KNOWOP  PASS
DEFENDED THEM, AND LOOK THEMTHN
OVERE
GO IO THE PIF YOU'RE H , THEY'R
THE RSEE WHEN
YOU GO IO E TO
YOU SEE POLICE DYO FACES. THEIR
IN THE BY WRITING  SUSPECT
A LETTER TO THE ATTORNEY
RAICE NC UNEQUALG
ISSU  FOLKS FROM 6t
A WAY TH IALOO MUCH.
>> IF I WERE MERRILAND, I ULHA
N  CLEARLY WHY
CONSPIRACY CHARGES.NG SIONAL
OIO GO
N STED.RS ANYEARS.E OP
THGHT
NOW.
IT'S PROBABLY GOIN BO OR
THREE YEARS BEFORE WA
>>HEA POLITICAU WRITOUT ALMOST
ER AMANDA,HIN THE
REPUBLICAN PS TRYING
TO WTE WASH WHAT HNE
TREN A, WHICH IS SCARYERE'S
SENATOR WHO HAS BEEN IN THE F T
OVTHE RESULTS OF T
ELECON
ARIZONA TO REVIETH A
THERE.TO TAL
PRESS.AN TRACKED DOWN MASSAND H
REALLY TWILIGHT CONVERSATION
WITH HIM, AND I WANT TO PLAY A
LITTLE BIT OF IT RIGHT NOW.
LISTEN.
>> IT'S ONE THING YO
KNOW JUD
RULEAGMS, AND THE COUNTRY THAT
LOT H OF THEAR
APPOINTED JUDGES, MAE EVEN IN
THE SUPREME CO
DO YOU THINK THE PEOPLE ARE
ABOVE THE COURTS?
THIS IS UNTR LAW.
YOU KNOWNALD T
EXPECTED THE SUPREME COURT --
>> WHERE DO WE DERIVPOWER,
THE GOVERNMENT?
>> WE THE PEOPLE.
>>E THE PEOPLE. HEOURTS.
>> YOU GUYS -- YOU GUYS AR
ABOVE THE COURTS.
>> BE CAREFUL OF TWISTING.
AN PA
YOU MADE AN ION.
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS I WORK IN
THE JUDICIAL -- NOT JUDICI-
LEGISLATIVE.
YOU GOT ME FLUSTERED.
WOULDT THEM T
HERE AND VOTE?RAID OF
TRANSPARENCY.
>> I'M NOTAID OF NOTHING.
>> YOU'RE
YOU'RE AFRAID.
FORENSIC, AND I WONDER WAR AFRA?
>> THE TRUTH!
>> WHAT'S HEARTBREG I
MED IN MY SPEECH, VE TER ELECTI
AFD ELECS.HE HELE TALKING ISTANP
T?
>> I MA LO T
A LOT OF DHE
ELAT WE TALKHIS THREAT MOVEMENT
IT IS G.YOI KEEP THING ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ORIZONA WITH
THIS F.
ESSENTIAY IFOURED TH
SEIZE TH.GOE TIMACHINES DS ONSP
THEY COUNT,
RE REA
ISHIN BREAK ELECTION
MA TAK OFFLINE
THROUGH THIS M
, CONSPIRATHEORI,
OCCURRENCE NOW. ECTION OFFICIALI
NTELLEABTH LASTING IMPACT, AYO
SAMI T U.S.
DEMOCRACY BY SAYING THEY HAVE
BETTER ELEIO AFGNI
IT IS -- STUNNING DOESN'T
BEGIN TO RECOV I>>R ID
PARTY.
>> HE IS.
>> HE TALKS ABOUT THBEIN HIM.OP